we are live for the back I saw what
could the punches for we're winners win
our special guest here Ari Shaffir since
thanks yes Ari auction you were at the
comedy store last night all our crowd
was great
we're great I [ __ ] midnight yeah Jeff
had a spot it's fall 15 people were
still there I mean they poured out a
little bit after after our da stage
you're like okay do you have a midnight
spot I don't know I mean I moved out to
11:45 with the spot why did you go why
did you go so late yeah I was gonna say
you must have asked for that even David
goes why are you before our oh I don't
know it's garbage up early it's [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] it's a it's like a it's
like a sprint it's easy it's like a
victory left I want from it's where the
corporate clowns go up yeah yeah I said
that yeah he said it I said it I just
said oh you said it he's got yeah it's
later I just yeah yeah by the way it was
still great last night [ __ ] then so
it doesn't matter yeah it is showcase I
would do it at 10 o'clock right if you
have people coming no industries and
guys hanging out till midnight
no but boom Shakalaka yeah the industry
the dates like no dresses like they're
talking 24 you know those guys yeah try
to be super cool oh my god hey bro hey
random Jew your [ __ ] dork get out of
here I don't care if you [ __ ] look at
the [ __ ] random Jew yeah hey random
Jew or like a tiny man hey tiny guy tiny
guy that works with CA a tiny guy
there's and they just saw that you just
seem like just buzzing all over the
place and all the cameras don't where
were you seven years ago and all they do
is pick up any young comic that has like
any kind of like someone decent set it's
varying like this kind of look when you
see Christmas presents are out you would
know that you but the rest of you guys
don't care you bring
guys uh where's the camera here we go
and that's the magic of Ari Shaffir live
in studio
Artie how's New York going New York's
gonna just got cold
would you ever move back there's a
possibility but no I don't really think
about so many garbage people - are you
king of New York I feel like you're king
of New York one of the people who run
the conversation yeah New York City
performer it's great so art can you get
into the UH the drama of last week Kurt
Metzger I haven't talked about a moose
gomez what is going on
you have ethnic and a guy who's probably
on the spectrum going at it what's going
on with that well Kurt is mostly in the
air to fall so that's ethnic - really
yeah
what is he Z Jew he's an oath just like
a giant dummy he's in town moves slowly
he moves like like a uh okay uh what are
those extinct elephants what are those
called
yeah yeah he moves like a woolly mammoth
really mammoth yeah I don't know they
got to a fight that they're a chose
throats Mets he goes for the jugular
verbally Lewis does that physically so I
mean but this is a running high right I
heard Kim Khan gotta hurt Annie came in
it was like guys come on what are you
fighting for and then she knocked the
glasses off her head and she goes let's
go [ __ ] and he's like wait what oh
really oh I wish I would know I would
have jerked off right there I'm gonna
start just stroking my dick Jimmy Lewis
upper fight yeah fine that's a hot fight
though dude who do you got that fight
okay yeah Kim always fights dirty and he
has no desire to fight so that sorry
she's at a disadvantage like hey what
are you doing what are you doing
I didn't know any and first came would
be like when you first the zombies when
you first realize they're zombies and
somebody's kind of like coming out I'm
not trying to fight the zombie back get
away man I'm gonna win that
oh yeah that's for sure so you don't
expect that's great Ari where are you
gonna be I'm gonna be and all things
comedy festival Phoenix I'll keep one
day this is what we're thankful for this
I love it this is great that lets me
what dating is like when you just bring
up one [ __ ] up you did have a [ __ ]
all the time remember that time I wonder
like that one time yeah November 12 2008
we [ __ ] up that one time where you
gonna be alright I'm gonna be things
Comedy Festival in Phoenix Arizona how
many shows you do it ooh punch-drunk
yeah to show the show at the Orpheum
another picture at the Orpheum
storytelling show that's it okay that's
a lot of shelves yeah in two days I
think nothing fry it may be a bit
guessing somebody else's show on Friday
I think not sure try to go hiking -
that's good to do in there in the desert
coho King those can't did it last year
with Danis any [ __ ] worth flip-flops
oh that's not the whole issue its
overall just entirety this is much for
the wilderness right there's never been
like it's probably the only show on
television that hasn't started you would
you agree with that well dinner stuff
yeah the with the Dungeness chew in the
desk with the gesture we have experience
with you guys go to the Bible to find
out what you're supposed to do yeah our
dad me and Dana Sande only
doing a live shooter table read my
script I wrote in college
oh so this is an 80 this is that happen
at ATC - no this will be happy to
remember 11th in New York how many fun
okay you got me excited it's gonna be
there ya know they're doing shows though
yeah I think so Neil where penis okay so
we're giving out other people's dates
now - they're not yours right you're
right who attracted the - nice Skylar
stones gonna be an arm Mississippi at
some point they're kind of part of the
show to be fair though cuz they dropped
the [ __ ] hot load your [ __ ] no
before that they called all the time and
they were do you remember the time you
guys inseminate it Oh something just
happen like we conceived on the 4th of
July science tells you and we're like
that's accurate we were together did you
did you what we doing that's accurate
like you're legally that was legalese
right there tell you the exact day yeah
what we do they tell you what palm do
anything he works and I just went over
and spent the night at his apartment
took that [ __ ] dick in his junior
puss did you guys who's in college
before that no they got pregnant
we got birth control what birth control
baby believed he believed the pried the
pill didn't work pharmaceutical
companies really [ __ ] it up yes the
doctors are like pissed cuz I took it
perfect they're like we hate having to
tell people this because then the
statistic goes down and like I set an
alarm every day and everything she
wanted to be born that baby like how
Rinna zzs like oh you're bringing into
the festival I'll babysit but I'm gonna
be at the pool the whole time is that
cool
Oh guys we're gonna be I'm gonna be at
the house of comedy
during the festival cuz that's my life
so go - are you really a house of comedy
yeah not it's not oh you
take off for the punch truck because
puncturing stir in a day and I might not
be there but guess who might show up
mr. Lucha Libre in a Mexican mask well
you're gonna be there we're just saying
that so people go see another show all
right okay but here's what we need by
the way let's put this out there we need
some local gays gays are coming they are
coming but we need if you're listening
right now we need some local gays if you
know some local gays we're doing this
scene this porn scene with Renat sleaze
is easy right a sleazy yeah and we need
some gays because it's gonna get gay
here's a religion right now forget the
9/11 thing it's hacky what we're gonna
do is we can concentrate on the chicken
parm have it yeah we're gonna be a lot
of lickin chicken parm
licking chicken we're gonna cower and
it's gonna be maybe a lady in the [ __ ]
but they'll be eating a sausage who's
writing it I'm writing I don't know
we'll figure that out those are good
notes
why don't we gonna be able to read the
script so we can give you punch ups to
notes what I'm not hiding it from you
but as I write it I would like to share
with you guys and finally ah yes if lies
would be good finally the following week
it's the tinfoil hat comedy tour myself
Eddie Bravo
uh I'm in Plano Texas it's me and myself
I'm at the hyenas and play no that's a a
clock show grab your tickets now Ellis
that's just outside Dallas and then the
following night it's myself at E Bravo
we're at the secret group in Houston and
then we're gonna go and I'll seriously
hang out with some [ __ ] black
strippers from Houston because they got
horses asses out there and then Sunday
it's again we're in Austin we're at the
stateside the Paramount stateside
theater in Austin go grab those tickets
now
should be fun hey real quick can we talk
about how all the things comedy is
chosen to promote our show did you see
this no oh I feel like our ease behind
Lisa Trager who is that is that a real
problem we rented in here go get Brenton
it
not fighting none of us know who that is
like we don't even get no more offended
fight nanny because the saw her picture
or Johnny cuz he's not even in it Oh
Johnny's not even in it yeah maybe
that's you and drag mocking typo because
he won't do his drag question what did
they Google's like my name and then like
that woman came up with nanny I don't
know maybe that's a nanny maybe that's a
weird nanny hook it's so offensive I
didn't call him in online cuz why she
should have put a pusher of [ __ ] wide
up a plan
clamshell what it was it's just that
it's not me should I text them get down
here we have questions yeah we want
answers we want answers our ease our
ease on the [ __ ] board here I'm on
the board of directors are you on the
board of directors board is it a board
of directors yeah what is just the board
oh okay I'm on the board I'm on the
board yeah I want answers and we all
know who the chairman of the board is
who carrot top carrot top so so what
kind of power do you have Ari
yes board ma'am I've power to yell
underling yeah I know how to abuse my
power do they know you're the boss here
why is anyone kissing this guy's ass I'm
ass right here yeah it's inflamed it's
blow now it's don't say you're gonna
miss it right there you can kiss it Ari
what's really weird about you is uh the
fact that you like to go out into the
wilderness and animals can smell blood
like if we brought the nanny out they'd
smell her bloody [ __ ] and they would
attack yeah your [ __ ] it's kind of
like that it's more dangerous I think
the problem though is the animals like I
smell but okay I figured this out yeah
it is literally an actress with your
exact name that I will not reveal on air
because you're the fine auntie I didn't
know if they would know my wife locked
out
it's so angry [ __ ] walks out of anyway
and you're so powers like come on stop
it stop it you get mad okay pretzel
look at you no this is ours your fear
I'm on the board on the board this is
how you promote our podcast
what do you see wrong there what do you
see it's gonna say if Brenton did it I
want to be right you know yeah three
ugly dudes and a hot chick that's gonna
sell some tickets okay okay all right
oh my god you're saying this [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] sell any tickets
with that [ __ ] gross face yeah I'm
not saying yet I'm saying Breton saying
yeah that's what you're basically so
here's the deal yeah send out to an
editor and I guess he doesn't watch the
show so he used the wrong photo obvious
I love that he's like I'll just figure
this out the one editor out of thousands
of editors who watch this show you found
the one that didn't know who find anyone
god damn internationally known locally
famous but then I put it up I didn't
double check because it's all things
comedy like all things double check your
work yeah yeah and I love how by the way
nobody looks like their picture that
that's Jason before he relapse from the
thousand times my awesome looking fat
Sam fat Sam is fat in that picture
my gosh you're not looking that fat
right now I'm not that fat belly no do
you remember when you said you were 185
and I was like let's no you're not yes I
am Michael's kind of scale we're not
doing that what are they bringing this
guy bringing this [ __ ] guy I'm on the
board on the board god damn it Mike yes
Mike take a look
get the [ __ ] out you're fired
that chick what if she shows up for real
just over that Photoshop even badly just
a picture of like a droopy [ __ ] [ __ ]
like a wet maybe [ __ ] Dover that can
we do that
Mike answers welcome at all fees comedy
yeah as a board member I think this is a
burning moment it is a loaded we should
lecture them on why this war member I
apologize to this podcast and to me Ari
I apologize to me like Hillary Clinton I
think responsibility it's not my fault
though but I take full responsibility
now Ari is a board member do you get
like cool things like 10% off dental
care and [ __ ] like that what do you get
well let me go to Beth DSi we get a high
for all your betting needs that's right
go to bat DSi and use a promo code punch
25 and guess what guys you guys get 25
dollars betting cash whatever you
deposit in you get doubled that okay
double that boom and it is betting
season everybody this is the best time
to be alive to ever hear that a story
about the gambler
it loses a bunch of money on football
then he lose his buddy but much money on
baseball then football and then
basketball and the basketball season is
over and it's like I gotta thank gamble
on the bookies like well you can give on
hockey it goes I don't know anything
about hockey that that's a great dad
joke was a nice long yeah you know what
bet the SI for all your baby needs bunch
25 you get $25 off 25 three dollars off
your first batting of day like
interactive re to gets in on it your
lock failed miserably last week by the
way San Francisco that was my walk away
today ones like the weeks worked what
did mine yeah
Tebow and Johnny we had the Saints
beating the Ravens or at least covering
I think they were dogs oh wow has drew
Brees is not thrown an interception yet
right that's pretty incredible
right that's pretty incredible Drew
Brees is not throw an interception this
year yeah
he's throwing a lot of [ __ ] passes
yeah the guy's gonna go down is like one
of the grace of all-time
Oh
gonna go down on my oh yeah poor dude no
interceptions second row second round
what picked 13 touchdowns 32nd pick the
entire football past item once yeah and
then San Diego let him go oh yeah I
remember you got hurt his arm was all
like twisted around gnarly dude NFL's
great like dude there's not like it's
either like a couple good teams that
everybody equally sucks oh yes it is
exciting as [ __ ] the problem Kansas
City's like can they beat New England no
defense they could have you can sure
they showed that they can beat them I
mean it's very show they can beat them
be a little different thing to play when
they went down when they went down in
the fourth quarter and they I'm sorry in
the third quarter and they scored a
touchdown to put him I think down to and
then they went for the one point
conversion so the point half a touchdown
you're like what are you doing go for
there and they go no we're gonna be just
going a lot more yeah is that gonna
matter and they yeah right they do do
they just got weapons everywhere and
they're young and but you know it's like
they better they better win now because
that quarterbacks gonna get a billion
dollars and not gonna be able to do jack
[ __ ] that's right can we talk about the
fight Chris Paul Rondo hi to former
players and my pelicans yeah oh I didn't
even think about that that I mean dude I
mean the good thing real quick a little
more NFL here and then we get our stock
Cowboys [ __ ] stuff that was a big
game you needed you couldn't get it now
did you guys get Amari Cooper cuz you're
supposed to trade for the charger from
but so are other teams so I don't know I
mean dude I mean this is worst-case
scenario for us his afford to Breton's
go 5050 from here on end yeah nobody
coach sucks right for Dallas I mean
carrots an idiot why is his clock
management at the end of that game was
terrible I mean they had like I'm full
minute they got two plays off no yardage
improvement garbage just they're garbage
he's garbage can say Garvin tent with
like alright well just it's like move
yeah yeah he's not good
they should get rid of him signed like a
real quarterback have a real coach do
you think anyone would ever trade for
Derek Carr yeah but not for not now you
won't get what you want yeah but what
would I get for you're better off having
him and hoping he turns it around then
what you'll get for him which is like I
take it you got it who wants it fourth
round pick
imagine the Jags got him for next year
how good would they trying to play
bortles they don't like him anymore
he sucks I just can't believe it I can't
believe he's ever good with that name
place mortals yeah you can tell by a
name how if a guy's gonna be okay really
really believe superstar named Blake
bortles not happen sounds like a street
you're embarrassed to live on yeah oh my
god you live on that [ __ ] yeah my Cam
Newton that's a guy that's gonna win
some yeah that's right yeah dang
Prescott
Cam Newton yeah how's he doing he's not
great but the name is not the problem
that's portal has a name it's the
problem that's true that's true
do you ever hear the story about way
like early in the NFL like in the 1950s
right really early how this one owner
just drafted the guy like in the first
round based on his picture
hahaha good throw he could do anything
yeah look it up that's hilarious yeah
for sure
I mean the Raiders I mean the good thing
about this week is they didn't play so
here Lou that's not bad so funny he's
like bro it's a 10-year plan bro and
your plans bro how much from all player
plays three years as a goon as a plan
dude 10-year plan I mean like I mean it
could not have gone worse this year yeah
yeah they were supposed to be good last
year they got hurt but they were
supposed to be good and then like I
don't get it I've talked about this on
our patreon ah it this all goes back to
when Derek Carr wouldn't kneel during
the anthem in that moment we're not
kneel yeah he wouldn't kneel everybody
kneeled yeah except him yep well yeah
you know how some people are kneeling
some people work you can't blame em for
not at that point that no
the linemen there's a big circle I enjoy
eating this yep and he got hurt on that
[ __ ] game and it's never been the
same the weird thing is like people some
people say like the white players are
like complicit in racism if they don't
kneel and they're like it's not a Amy
Schumer it's whoever it is but it's
there like it's not about it's not about
the army it's not about the flag it's
about cops but it's like okay but can
you see a world where these guys would
not have heard that where they do think
it's about the the [ __ ] flag yeah cuz
everyone's else besides you were saying
that yeah so don't say that complicit in
racism when they're getting a different
story than you I get it it should be
about the cops but like I don't like
everyone does the same research you do
yeah and this guy ed Reid I mean like
that's an example of dude who doesn't
learn lessons right but try again read
and read is alright last night Ted read
Jim read Jim really read can't read Eric
Eric Reid doesn't sound like a real
person God that does not sound like a
successful guy he almost started to
fight with another dude who started an
organization and took a hundred mil from
the NFL to stand yeah and then like
that's a million from the NFL the
organization that he created or
something saying as an NFL supported
puppet wait what what they say they said
if you stand we'll give you a million
dollars hundred mil one guy a hundred
million dollars he's organization if he
got everybody to stand can you look it
up I mean you know about it why I just
told you what are you well I don't know
anything about it so I don't think you
did your job if that's weird yeah so
yeah your job was a telescope on the
board he doesn't know what you're
talking about
he's on the [ __ ] board Malcolm listen
I'm sorry I'm not just some schmuck the
[ __ ] board I told the players
coalition's was okay and what is it
about
sounds like the rainbow colder yeah this
is pack butts is that what they do so
basically this guy was out of football
forever he couldn't get hired right Eric
yeah he didn't nobody sign him in the
offseason because he's part of this
kneeling thing yeah so after like a rash
of injuries all over the league
some teams are looking at him and I and
they signed him and he goes right back
to taking a knee which is fine line yeah
we're gonna lose our one black listener
Anthony Johnson he's gonna tweet us
about how he's not watching any sports
and he's watching the Panthers that's
the only team you watch I'm sorry I said
you've been shot by cops then shut the
[ __ ] up
quit bitching get out there and get shot
by cops if you're really black and you
care about the black experience to go
get shot by a [ __ ] cop you [ __ ]
sellout what is it Uncle Tom yeah Uncle
Tom Johnson okay this is it was created
by Malcolm Jenkins with the Players
Association they took close to 90
million dollars from the NFL for efforts
and programs combating social inequality
so whatever the like okay we're gonna go
do something I get it you guys are upset
about these captures let's join in with
you let's not do this because it's been
pasteurized does this ideas ambassador
eyes where everybody thinks against the
flag and against troops so what we're
gonna do is we're actually gonna get
behind your cause yeah I really like
let's actually do stuff that helps you
helps justice well Eric Reid called it
an NFL funded subversion group which I
thought you would like this oh god like
controlled opposition exactly yeah yeah
so now they're like now [ __ ] the NFL
it's like it's not [ __ ] the NFL the NFL
is never the problem yeah it's the cops
yeah you got just like they're shifting
it over to like it's about the troops oh
it's about the flag it's not about the
end if they're not practicing the NFL
the NFL is just like he was losing a
shitload of money
yeah is there another way you guess you
guys like cash do not press on my front
lawn yeah yeah it's interesting so like
we'll help you we'll help you we get it
will help you we're all black Oh Eric
Reid also called him a neo-colonialist
whoa I'm from you call me a neo-colonial
you better be ready to fight that's what
they were arguing about oh my god the
board you can't even open the door oh my
make Rachel get you coffee you piece of
[ __ ] see what happens when you're on the
board hey everybody
ABC's Josh wolf get that [ __ ] at all
gonna walk on the shirt off
oh no no this is a sports show let's
talk some sports real quick I know
you're busy getting it out separate
where Johnny is and he's a guy who looks
autistic sit where he is
why is Ari duder you guys to juice it
don't get along what's going on this is
some Jew Hans you cry we actually don't
mix well she's welcome to the show one
of my favorite people on the planet he's
got a show here on a TC called
controlled chaos controlled chaos Josh
wolf everybody this is the fight nany hi
how are you she got knocked up by a Jew
I did congratulations yeah and Andy have
you had the baby already yeah a boy or a
girl girl
yeah Jewish boys you know are born with
huge nuts really yeah
Jewish Jewish boys abnormally large nuts
no does he have any big nuts oh I do a
joke about a my special yeah yeah
there's the Jewish like I remember when
my youngest son was born I remember
thinking those are abnormally like the
cat in the cradle should be playing
about are we making a bet about the Sox
Dodgers I mean do you really think I
think it's I think it's wrong that the
Sox are so heavily favored ha ha ha
because the top to the Tigers Dodgers
top to pitchers that's a great hat by
the way thank you very much if that kid
can pitch I think they're top two we
were as good as the Sox top two and I
think that Dodgers bullpen is better I
think that people are looking at our
records and going that we're [ __ ]
mm-hmm but they don't realize is that we
started the season the worst ever for a
Dodger season yeah and so we were 10
games under 500 because our whole team
was hurt
so since that if you can take that out
there we've had one the best records in
a major league baseball the Dodgers yeah
those lawyers
yeah let's Dodgers and their bench by
the way like when you're bringing Puig
off the bench what is going on
I got this blister in this [ __ ]
rowing machine is that just water just
water
ok let me ask you answer are you older
are you into this in
analytics the way that I'd be if you
watch major-league base I mean you watch
the national league championship yeah
that was like the extreme version of
bottled the wall trying to get rid of
some of the water too high too high up
there is a lot of liquid happening over
over you got your bottles of water you
got new some neosporin or whatever that
is a problem I think I lives in the
wilderness guys I think I should the
Tebow [ __ ] relaxes on [ __ ] it I'll
take someone sip their own hand soup
yeah welcome yeah man I I'm not into
like you know the numbers guys and
they're talking about and when they talk
about war and oh shut up we're going to
war you're playing your bad baseball for
no no replacement yeah wins against
these guys [ __ ] battle yeah that's what
they do football yeah yeah so we're
going war Kellen Winslow
oh yeah well that guy got weird dude
I mean like if you saw what he got
charged with uh didn't get charged with
raping like a seven year old or 80 year
old woman ah I don't know man I thought
that was just statutory rape reverse
statutory yeah you mean so once you get
too old you're beyond consent - yeah oh
yeah yeah that's interesting really want
it you know they want it's interesting I
make but you're below a certain age but
there could be you're above a certain
age for consent at some point in time
yeah for the grossest factor yeah I mean
dude I mean like I have a joke about
it's pretty much gotten hacky but it's
like the the senior citizens have the
highest rate of STDs because they just
go the whole home and he just bought
everybody bones also because I went to
[ __ ] one senior citizen and then it
spread cuz they all heard that yeah you
know but what I here's the thing that I
don't quite get about that right so say
are we talking baseball war we're
talking about a nursing home okay so
here's what I don't get so say I'm 85
years old
yeah and
I have an 85 year old body yeah but I
don't think that when I'm alive
by the way you'll still be ripped I hope
so I don't think that when I'm 85 my
brain will think I want an 85 year old
body yeah you always want 23 old Hotch's
so so fun so so like so that's my point
like I'm not sure if when you get older
your dick doesn't work I just think
maybe you see a naked old woman you're
like I'm not [ __ ] pass on that yeah
yeah you know what I mean I'd say my
women right where it's like that's all I
can get I don't want yeah I'm gonna read
how about because you're fat doesn't
mean you want fat people yeah it means
that's all I can get so if I get too
hard up yes so what I'm saying I'm not
the same way people like people like I
will never disown my age like why you're
[ __ ] your age and I can't that's
gross
yeah I don't know why they're doing you
I just did you see that article about
the guy who married his daughter's best
friend yeah now she's heard the best
friend's stepmom yeah he's the and so
she's 27 or something and he's getting
ripped he's like a Josh wolf he's 52 and
so I heard I read a bunch of these
comments online about how [ __ ] gross
and that's why Shue says that women say
that women say it because they would get
so angry I'm not gonna say me this they
sent me a story about Dane Cook yeah and
how'd you know 19 year old 19 year old
she's 19 now yeah when they start dating
dude a summary one now when my wood
model is he my daughter was in high
school she was 18
yeah and there was this dude who was 22
who was coming around a dater and I told
him straight up if I see you at the
[ __ ] high school man I'm gonna punch
you so hard you're a grown up
I better not see you in a car picking up
somebody from the [ __ ] high school
and he was like yeah but she's 18 I go I
don't give a [ __ ] what I see what's
legal is not what's right yeah she's in
high school but I will say like when I
date young girls I don't mean like 23
year old something like that a lot of
people like Oh aren't they stupid and
I'm like feminist who say that I'm like
are you kidding are you calling 23 year
old woman's stupid
yeah we're just stupid when they're
dating an older person because
when they're normally just 23 and out in
the world you like they're brilliant
they can do anything they're fierce yeah
and then suddenly they're dumb yeah when
it goes in relation to that yeah in high
school it's like you don't have all your
wherewithal but also that chick hate in
high school that chick when she's that
model hot that's beyond Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue at 16 you
ain't much she's been beyond high school
guys yeah who's a stains girl yeah we
didn't you go to high school with Pete
with girls who just never dated dudes in
high school and always dated college or
in college was like so if he's Dana has
been Dana when she's been legal I have
no problem with that
it's a weird relationship and by the way
the only people who think it's gross at
a forty-five or fifty year old whereas
dating are like 35 and up year old wimp
I want that that's ridiculous oh they
were 19 they didn't think anything was
wrong times by the way I don't
understand why anyone cares who somebody
else is [ __ ] well I mean as long as
they're League legal that's what I mean
that's it but like always just gossip
that's really what it is though really
cares
she's really nice they don't care
anything about to what they encode does
or how much she tips or anything like
that babies in this weird world that no
matter what he does he's he'll go nuts
yes yeah yeah yeah I think he like he
paid his price at some point I never had
to be able to you know walk and by the
way he stole from you you were saying
that it's [ __ ] big he threatened you
yeah here's if you keep doing the bit I
stole from you oh really
well no but you're right I was almost 20
years ago yeah it was almost no problems
with him I mean weeds were working on a
project they ghosted that drove me nuts
plastered as a term your daughter would
use yeah you know and it's fine but at
the end of the day it's like he seems to
be just doing his thing he you know the
one thing I will tell you is that you
know with the history they had with
people he doesn't hang out in comedy
club now he does the big complaints like
hey dude you can't why are you pumping
people why are you stealing jokes yeah
so it's like I'll just not do stand-up
get out and I have no problem with that
you know it's interesting I was just
thinking about because you said I
complete double standard sitting here
somebody else's daughter I got no
problem with him dating 51 year old yeah
but if you told me that my daughter was
gonna date some dude my age he and I
would have tab yeah [ __ ] shut up so
here's here's why this double standard
if there's a if your daughter was safe
16 and there was a 16 year old who was
kind of a dirtbag who also wanted a
dater you'd also have a problem yes
so yeah yeah what you want for your
daughter that's not really so back to
this this world series that's kitchen
beef are you gonna grow any games I'm
gonna go to the games here that's that's
what I hate is that there's gonna be so
many Red Sox do disagree tons of Dodgers
fans in Boston I don't think so there's
gonna be more put their [ __ ] up on
StubHub anyone can buy it
there's gonna be every time the Red Sox
are here there's a lot of Red Sox fans
it but I think you're right I think
there are people with money who are
gonna have money they live in boss and
the limit East Coast they never get to
see the Dodgers play and they'll go I
think they'll travel I'll tell you what
though I'll tell you what though
la is more of a transient town yep so
like people like me people like you Sam
we're not from here right and there's a
lot more of that but a lot less people
move to Boston you know I mean so it's
like we have people that are like all
the agencies have season yeah it's but
like we don't really care about this
just like something we take our I
thought you were a Dodgers fan and you
lived in New York City yeah would you
try to make it in for a game catch a
train right absolutely yeah yeah sure
thank you we haven't so at the Houston
uh Yankee series last year and there are
tons of Astros tons right yeah I think
the Dodgers but they travel - yeah
Dodgers all teams they're a lot of
people leave I mean it sounds crazy but
a lot of people do leave LA I mean
they're like [ __ ] too much traffic and
like when the when the Dodgers played
like that the Diamondbacks it is all
Dodgers and yeah there's a home game for
them it's gonna be interesting I think
would have been worse if the Yankees
were in there cuz I feel yeah are you
gonna go to any games
I'm unfortunately out of town during it
I went last year
Romilly water what is the what is the
what are the game one tomorrow it's two
games in Boston
did they take a day off if I record if I
okay so know that stop they have they
went back to record yeah I went back you
look at 2 3 2 or the 2 2 1 1 1 I thought
2 3 - well in baseball has to be like
that that's how baseball is cuz babe
it's almost like do you know in cricket
one game last three days yeah so think
about baseball it's like that's really
what a series is do you want to win the
game or do you want win the series that
baseball's just like there's too many
people moving it's just it's really
don't you think that the three games at
home actually benefits the away team
because its source here to win two in a
row than it is three is but you'll win
two out of three I think it right but
but but home teams a lot of times sweep
the - oh right and then use and then now
it's now it's now you're down 3-2
yeah up 3-2 going back do you know what
I mean like I always feel like that
three games in a row always benefits the
away team because even but I do and then
lose one on the then it's like [ __ ] now
we're on three one and God go back to
them yeah baseball's weird I mean that
it's just like they do back to backs no
other sport does that I mean fact is
though if it's 2 3 2 or 2 2 1 1 1 at 6
games you've each had the same amount of
home games yep
so if the six game series which a lot of
them are you know it's not gonna matter
and at 4 game if it's a sweep also
doesn't matter it's also even I left a
message for Kato Kaelin because he's a
big Brewers fans yeah and that game was
lost by their manager yeah their manager
put in that one guy that pitcher that we
have lit up every time
yep we lit him up see all the home games
we lit him up let's now work lit lit up
yep every time he's in we light him up
yeah Jeffress yeah and when he came and
I go I can't believe they're putting
this another [ __ ] in now and we boat
we went 3 on him I go every time it is I
don't even have [ __ ] numbers in front
of me I've watched these guys play
enough to know that dude we have his
number I and I gotta tell you man
everybody my friends all texting me just
gonna crook I look at the Dodgers lineup
I'm like this is a good from what that's
an American League lineup
queeg is not the guy who was but he's
still feared Oh
yeah and play and Machado is a monster I
want Machado when they like he's Geordi
I want to like ya different he's gone
straight he'll though if you look at his
interviews now he's embraced being the
bet the WWE in the Yankees by the way
his hair cut is straight he'll drop
he'll though he's gone straight looks
like a bad guy from what was that blue
steel what was the awful Ferrell movie
us Zoolander Heyman Puig should do it
like a WWE Tag Team bad guy wrestling
like bass also weird it's like the only
one where it's like they have these
old-school rules I don't like it and
they're like oh dude it's all to it you
mean like when they didn't let black
people play kind of rules where the [ __ ]
out they'd prefer Mike Trout to yasiel
puig and I would rather have Puig is
great the boringest the I get you're
saying they're so you'd rather have like
he would rather have just a quiet dude
no that's not true man they like you
they don't just start tweeting more but
they don't they don't like the show of
emotion they don't they're they're the
one league that always comes down old
guard ya ears don't like it the guys who
run Major League Baseball look around
and how do you like the bat flips I like
the back flips contact sports so like
[ __ ] who cares if there's a little
bit of it I totally agree in basketball
if you get dirty someone's gonna go out
so I'm gonna get injured for a long time
yeah you know it's putting shitty few
football it's like you go low you could
end up guys career baseball a little
dirt it's nothing no trash talk is
nothing and the baseball fights are the
worst they're just all a bunch of pushin
there's one fight that people are still
talking about Robin Ventura that that's
the sign of like wow went that far was
just some punches no the Yankees versus
Red Sox when he tossed Zimmer to go yeah
toss the old man down that was a great
fight this year when the Red Sox and
Yankees when the bench is cleared it was
so funny to see because I don't think a
team has ever been so large where they
got Sanchez Stanton and just fix a judge
and stand and start to run down the
field and you could just see just people
just move
moving out of the way like we're not
fighting these [ __ ] monsters he's my
age when he's doing that who Ryan oh
that's like 46 in this dude it puts his
glove down calm like old man give me
wine I want to see how he ducked his
head low here we go he went down to
tackle early on why'd you give him your
head that's just a bag because these
guys never fight I know but I go for a
single leg or go high single leg don't
grow tomatoes don't just give him like a
deity yeah but when you seven six eight
guys coming at me it's scary but I
guarantee you this dude judge never been
in a fight I guarantee he's never had a
fight like you ever see one Shaq threw a
punch he doesn't know how to throw a
punch doesn't he didn't know now he does
you ever seen me do bulldoze LJ yeah oh
that was a great but LJ got inside of
new polls Larry Johnson yeah and they
just lit him up from inside yeah golden
clubs but but yeah when Shaq threw that
punch he threw it from back here and
that dude is so lucky it missed his head
he won I don't was looking at Williams
yeah yeah this was a great fight too
dude some great punches thrown in there
it's the first basketball fight besides
some sucker punches where people have
been facing up look at thug Brandon look
at me sting comes in and yells at the
ref I couldn't believe that yeah you got
right look at this [ __ ] that dude I'm
like whoa and look Lance Stevenson's the
voice of reason never happens but the
spit it was such a low-key spit right
there yeah look at I did not see it you
can't see it when you there's a video
you can see where you zoom in close up
see Randall spits right in his face oh
really it's a close-up video so it's
just talkin spit it was nose but though
the Rockets sent to Siberia what so they
he spit on me man
yeah right by the way spitting I always
remember if somebody spits on you that
is like a first pun don't you think yeah
no no I think that was legally they were
like that's enough because you can't not
fight back so that's like that's called
the first punch to me spitting on
somebody look at watch watch and he'll
wipe his face see that I didn't see the
spit though well you go from the side
they show from the side here we go here
we go
yeah and they're gonna close up on his
mouth oh I see that oh yeah he gave it
to him he gave it to him so he didn't
want to be seen on film but he's that's
a spit on somebody no no no anything but
he's right in his face right in his face
exactly and if you wanted to do that you
could attorney
oh nice punch though yeah but he
definitely spit on yeah I'm with you if
somebody splits on you you have no
choice oh yeah Leena and he wipes his
fellow whoa that's a spit what is this
like super a film I don't think if
someone spits on your face like Paul got
suspended I don't know why he's getting
suspended what do you mean through
bachelor stuff but what do I know
exactly what do you expect him to do
if someone spit in your face as a
clipper and we played them last night
and beat them I'm fine with them well
like right yeah that's let's say what
let's say I want to put like took two
punches at you and then you punched back
why am I getting so yeah it's like what
do you want to keep walking away
someone's punching me yeah that's what
it's not realize they're never
understood that like maybe that deserves
a fine now I lied to Larry Johnson the
new bull fight yeah I would love to do
that by the way Chris Paul is not like
an angel on the court no dude I know
commercials rolling or [ __ ] dirt bags
yeah yeah
I mean that was a shot to the nuts you
saw that one before right yeah yeah that
is like oh that was way backwards but Oh
Nana's he's he's a little [ __ ] talker
he's not that loved which is very weird
like you know what he met his fan wise
or player wise player was why oh really
cuz he's super intense like he's super
interesting better I loved him on the
Pels yeah I mean like the problem with
him hell yeah
boom oh man want Hold'em oh my new pool
gets through a lot of fights yeah
I mean oh whoa that punch came from like
I did a lion when I was 13
yeah you know what I love about his
punches they're all over the head open
hand it's pure WWE [ __ ] yeah
like that Street Fighter the tie box
hell yeah thank you from across the room
oh yeah dude they got to do a 30 for 30
in that time a new poll hit six threes
in a game yeah yeah what he gets six
Linda combs forever by the way Doug
Christie like she finally divorced his
wife why do you think the best
basketball fight the bet forget
basketball what's the best sports fight
you've ever seen well the best
basketball fight has got to be Julius
Erving versus Mary Jo jumps up and just
start swinging Bert he gets knocked down
and they're like let it happen did you
see when somebody uh-oh malice was
pretty good too oh you know it was good
to the uh-oh door punching Bautista last
year in the face oh yeah he was enacted
that was the first baseball punch I've
seen where you could see that dude's
knees went a little wobbly
yeah but teased his knees went a little
wobbly like Oh door got him square I
love a good fight lamb but your sports
bike yeah do you know what they did when
they were tired limber is jerseys ever
tell you this no all the ushers it was
his you know retirement ceremony all the
ushers were destructed as you're showing
people their seat give him a cheap shot
watch this is the cheapest punch I've
ever seen right here and this is my man
oh that's even he wasn't even up with
him no that's the chief he they hated
him so much everybody why do you think
he has to coach the WNBA do you if you
if you're a basketball team though do
you want Bill Laimbeer on your team if
you're picking a team right and you're
like man we got a spot you want somebody
like man be on your team yeah absolutely
he puts a bull's-eye on your team like
he puts a target on your team every time
you no one's got your back a thousand
percent yeah this what I talk about Luis
Gomez
I was talking to Edgar about it and it
was like he seems a little too agra agro
and I'm like here's the deal with Luis
Gomez if I if he walks into a bar comes
back from the bathroom and I'm in
someone's face he doesn't ask questions
he just punches that guy yeah that's a
guy you want that's a guy that's a guy
we are my biggest opinion is this I wait
what happened to his face yeah what
happened there Tyler Hansbrough he was
great to cumin seeds
wait 14 seconds left and up 14 that
looks like but oh no what happened to
him oh dude you know Johnny jerks off to
this [ __ ]
Bhoomi comes out of nowhere oh I
basically go punch came right in the
face yeah
down 12 or 14 seconds left oh you know
do you think they like you secretly hate
each other I think they like each other
but I think she's Jessica bright they
should be like I'm really sorry man that
was [ __ ] ridiculous oh I'll take care
of it he defended it
Jeff's keys scum what'll he say anybody
they said was awful how could that be an
accident hey that guy's nose fell down
Oh the ball was already hit him with his
elbow yeah
how do you miss with the elbow to his
okay you don't miss the ball was way
gone and went up and then he was like
always there elbow he didn't miss at all
no totally connected I don't think I've
ever seen a good football fight
obviously cuz everybody's helmets are on
yeah unless you get those ones where
that do where they start swinging their
helmet at each other those are always
well the truth is like there's the re so
much violence that they can just legally
take it out on each other
that's like hockey you know they could
light it well hockey they'll fight but
like they can just go up and lady do a
dude up and hockey in oh she went down
the middle I don't have to punch you I
can just [ __ ] yeah off on you the best
was Oakley Charles Oakley oh you get
people's face and he was like hey let's
not do this here cuz they're gonna break
it up about a meet you up to the [ __ ]
game yeah I'll meet you out back we hung
out with a loading dock star don't kick
your [ __ ] ass that's the guy who did
that Rasheed Wallace did he go on
somebody else's bus Rasheed Wallace
didn't care you know what the fight I
always wanted to say for real was
Anthony Mason vs. Charles Oakley oh that
would have never happened my teammates
for too long well yeah but they were it
was bull the Knicks were a little bit
like I when they were bulls and Knicks
hold on if he mace was on the Bulls
no no Oakley was on that boat yeah and
Mason was on the Knicks really both such
[ __ ] bruisers yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but in Mason whoa look at
nobody can throw punches
nobody Pippen this [ __ ] thing still
in the closet back there
oh you see now the rules in hockey like
I do like once you go to the ground you
they hands off yeah but you can tell
when they hate each other because if
they're still throwing punches when they
get to the ground that is a [ __ ] oh he
punched the referee cause he couldn't
land one on Pippin how about the refs
they have to run a lot they have to run
a lot oh yes you're not supposed to do
that oh oh
somebody just throw knee a flying knee
yeah he's the goalie you see now the
team you know you're not supposed to do
that you know like they're trying to get
rid of fighting in hockey like that was
like that was what you would pray for as
a fight yeah this is the reason you
watch yeah when they put off fighting
into the into the video game yeah but
whoever lost the fight will get the
penalty these are the worst what you're
in full whatever do you member when that
guy on the Bears picked up the [ __ ]
Packer I think it's slander the ground I
think was a refrigerator oh it's the
other way around where they they threw
down all my oh yeah man threw him down
like one of those bodies jobs over the
bags yeah dude
Odell Beckham is not worth the trouble
would you trade him worth the trouble
man I thought he's so young what you do
is a lie Manning has to say right now
he's like hey guys it's my last year so
help me enjoy my last 12 games man 10
games she trade him let's trade on
Jaguars now he's not gonna get anything
he's gonna be ridiculous they're not
competing this year and he's gonna be a
lifer tell me that wasn't [ __ ] dude
get rid of the bat get rid of the bat
first please get rid of the bat for the
these these series like in the stands if
you've ever been have you been you been
- oh here it is here it is my favorite
ceiling - get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] down
man I mean by the way what was immer
thinking he was never apologized after
that but what was the best outcome for
Zimmer like what am I thinking
that's what it was yeah the only getting
slammed
his head to the ground what do you think
what's gonna happen like that is always
and look at him hard okay yeah such a
rush now he's getting the [ __ ]
lightheadedness from that from an
adrenaline dump yeah I mean you ever get
into talking with a manager realize
dropped lightheaded
by the way what's this dude's name
Finnegan Christian Finnegan I thought
you'd probably gotten more not Christian
Finnegan atomic what's his last name
dude Anthony Johnson Finnegan he was so
good he never had this debacle
quarterback Courtland Finnegan must have
been punched more time he just walks
away a lot talks it slots and he walks
but he why cuz he's annoying he's
annoying
so a street ball and then the balls at
the top of the key and you're all like
on the on the wing and the right in your
[ __ ] face
by the way light-skinned brothers love
that a haircut by the way every time
they got that weird
Sideshow Bob haircut anybody up nope on
that well as EQ Elliot's got a bad one
oh yeah they love that [ __ ] thank God
the balls got rid of it dude like they
had that weird [ __ ] pump stupid by
the way how quiet is the daddy live all
day dude they they [ __ ] muted it I
think starting so he's like what am I
gonna say but do you think that was part
of the Brawn coming over like listen I'm
happy to come over guess who has to shut
the [ __ ] also a lot of the ball I think
somebody might come over because he was
saying he's better now than LeBron is he
goes well I'm here we can play anytime
yeah let's play before practice dude
listen
the Lakers pulled aside ESPN they go
listen can you stop where your radio
station you we're big draw for you if
you continue to interview this guy we're
gonna stop that that's all gonna come to
an end
because eventually their their contract
with 710 out here is gonna come on yeah
and they're gonna be like [ __ ] you we
told you not to [ __ ] you know
interview the ball HS have they they
probably took him away from [ __ ] I
didn't make a rule that you can't
interview anybody I'm getting to four
players yeah you know you know really
yeah he's such a Lavar ball is such a
prime example of for me about what like
the scariest things about America right
now is that all you have to do is is is
get a platform and just say ridiculous
[ __ ] and people will follow you
yeah it doesn't it really doesn't matter
right really doesn't matter right or
wrong if you stand in it and you just
say it with confidence you're gonna get
a lot of people talking about [ __ ]
believe that you know there's certain
people out there I'm not gonna give any
specifics that are so they get addicted
to tweets and retweets hmm and like they
just start saying the crazy [ __ ] cuz
they're getting all their weights
weights and there's virtual signaling
where it's like is it so crazy to think
that everyone's equal well depends what
you get for getting rid of the whole
time that he is 24 though he is part of
your future and by the way anymore yeah
yeah and by the way you know the one
good thing is that Jerry Jones is not
scared to trade away a bunch of draft
picks I love how they get he's not
scared to show no shaking Photoshop
anybody so now that immediately put him
in a cowboy Rosa it looks flawless Yeah
right that is so crazy
I can't believe for what for what though
it's gotta be like vertical earlier
there's got to be a number one draft I
don't know how because he was he was a
first-round draft it seems to me what
Gruden is doing is he's getting rid of
everybody in the locker room who may not
be his guy and he's going to he's knows
he's got ten years every build he's
gonna take a beating for two or three
years in the press and I think he's got
in his mind by this time I will have
stockpiled enough draft picks and people
to build a team first rounder first
rounder for next year first rounder we
got laughing that's a mid round first
rounder the Cowboys you play like eight
and eight probably yeah probably
I mean Chicago keeps I mean they were
looking good they've lost some close
close games Cowboys got fleeced is what
that guy says yeah that's a collar do
you do you or how matter you yeah by
getting cuz they're that dual Mac but
the number that the what's was a
cornerback they drafted last year the
year before yeah Corey
he's on the block to who are you Joe so
they put him on the block yesterday
putting my not get [ __ ] for that's what
I think too if your season's gonna suck
let's start and he'll build your team it
like dude here in the NFL or even the
NBA if you
you should be tanking well yeah but that
sucks so bad it's a lot for the first
six games of season you still have a
chance even if you're like two and four
if we can get both up yeah that kid that
got hurt but he was like a monster at
Ohio Satan in here he's like I'm out
what a great move by the way smartest
thing he ever done by the way he quits
he's out and then BOOM Ohio State just
goes to [ __ ] I hate the people who were
who are getting on this kid if I'm 20
years old 19 years old and you've got an
abdomen issue which those if you ever
tore muscle does some of your abs those
oh those those slinger but they also if
you don't if you [ __ ] around with it and
you go out and you play when you still
kind of have it it leads to other
injuries so you telling me he should
risk his financial future cuz that's all
they are they're not really there to
play for Ohio State they're not really
rep there I mean you know that's a nice
bonus but like that's not really there
but it's a trade school show yeah and so
if if Ohio State is gonna say this and
you come back and play and if you get
injured we're gonna guarantee you 20
million dollars then I would do it but
if you're not gonna guarantee me the
money I know I'm gonna make why am i
risking that for you yeah I know and I
don't even understand the people who are
going crazy are these college kids man
remember Mike McCaffrey sat out that
bowl game right yeah I would have done
the same thing yeah if you know it's a
basketball where the odds of getting
injured or minor every extra game in
football is like you got a chance to go
yeah what's that kid Marcus Lattimore
yeah for South Carolina where you had
two of those injuries that needs me
again yeah what they do is as soon as
you're like a number one high level guy
you should be you should have somebody
be allowed to get your insurance for you
so you get five million dollars Iran
with Josh wolf he's got he's controlled
chaos this one three where you calling
from where is that so I got I'm down the
street I've heard some rumors about the
Raiders and by the training away so many
players let's get this inside scoop for
a guy okay from Chicago who's got in
I scooped about some going on Oakland
let's hear it oh I only have the inside
scoop because they traded Cleo Mac and
the reason I heard the trade Cleo Mac
was because he was caught slugging John
Gruden's wife his wife is [ __ ] Cooper
and Mac sounds realistic but do it
reverse
there was a train rat on his wife then
it all makes sense
by the way start the rumor right now
that should be a porno series would you
like to come on tinfoil hat you should
do a month of tinfoil hat sports
conspiracies it's it's a great let's
here i let's hear it so the thing about
Tiger Woods winning but they're the PGA
Tour's yeah but his wife was totally
okay with him hooking up just not with
women don't used to turn to you know so
he [ __ ] John Drury okay [ __ ] hookers
better make you can play better
I was thinking hanging up when you
immediately without saying anything but
now I'm I'm really happy I did not what
else you got I like this so I like this
Tiger Woods these rumors are like
ridiculous but also kind of like they're
like fear baby like where's Alex Jones
okay you got anymore
what's your name yeah what's your name
you're our conspiracy consult number so
that we know that he's calling in so
with these scoops Johnny thank you
you're a hot scoops correspondent what's
your name buddy hot scoops what do you
want to go at roots right room arathi
Ruben arrived
6:3 alvarado you should start calling
the Raiders rumors groomers yeah I
respect that
oh you made room arathi laughs you
cracker Brock you know you're a real
common thanks for [ __ ] great thanks
out of those two which one do you think
is more likely out of though if you if I
was the only one she was real one of
these two is regular would sorta seems
gay for sure I believe if you would read
Kaleo Mac and not also a Mary Cooper
maybe it trains a train dude a train no
one man train well dude it's like uh
where'd they just say that there was a
huge rumor that somebody's [ __ ]
somebody's girl that happens constantly
all the way the trades are like other
goes into if you do that which is happy
Butler was banging cat yeah yeah John's
an axe they said women are scandalous
and they threatened to disrupt the
[ __ ] whole I did look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's one of us and then she's
[ __ ] another one yeah I'm gonna tear
everything apart oh yeah right there
I like how we gotta tell you that beanie
is not doing him any just I said cover
up the AIDS [ __ ] yeah shows first first
on the head I mean absolute I mean like
everybody's just banging everybody like
like you had launched a but what's the
point of like what's the point
so my question name would be like hey we
want you to Vanity Fair
great hey we want you and I would and
they suggest this why say yes to this
because he's a he's a because you got
talking trust us we're great were great
and then you just do it I know exactly
but this is why when you're doing like a
TV show like a hosting like let's try
one where you do it like this and you're
like I don't like that be like let's
just try it you're like no because then
it's up to you so yet say I don't ever
want that so no we're not doing one just
for saying you know that happened the
exact thing happened to me so I
unfortunately like at the very beginning
of when I was do
my little talk show there I had a little
run and they wanted to do like um a
sizzle package to run you know for a
couple months before you on CMT oh
that's all right so we're doing this
thing that guy goes hey man so for the
opening of the show we have this
crosswalk can you do like dancing feet
on the crosswalk yeah and I was like he
was like kind of like Tom Hanks and big
you're playing the piano with your feet
but for the crosswalk and I was like no
I because I said these are kind of
things that I'm gonna say no and you're
gonna say just do it and I'm gonna say
okay but don't air it and it's gonna end
up it's not why are we even wasting the
film that's why we don't want it so that
happened he said to me he goes well I
have it here that the network wants to
see it so let's just shoot it I go ok
let me tell you something I'm gonna
shoot it but if it comes back because I
get final I'm just gonna take it out
sure enough it opened with me doing the
dancing [ __ ] feet and I call the
network and I was Ike hey I was really I
think it was pretty specific when I said
this dates it it seems like in 1970s or
80s and it's terrible and it's stupid
and it's not my personality dancing on a
[ __ ] sidewalk crosswalk and they said
well test audiences I'm like you did not
send the opening to the test audience
yeah you're not saying yeah okay test
that means you have to come back to me
and say hey Josh just you know it tested
really well and I feel safe stake it out
yeah they didn't do that they just go
test audiences
well they ended up thankfully they ended
up taking it out but it was one of those
just like you said they just want you to
shoot it and once I shoot it and they
want all bets are who knows yeah but you
know this is corny and you guys don't
know what's cool what's not i Dukes I'm
the artist yep so [ __ ] let me [ __ ]
do it it's amazing how we have people
who have no entertainment talent at all
deciding entertainment and it's not even
that you see this like on the road with
some comedy clubs right we're like some
guy was the a food and beverage dude at
TGI Fridays and there's an opening at
the Chuckle Shack and he gets hired
there and now he's he's not only GM yes
watching comedy and telling us whether
it's funny or not the duty is that
Nickelback is telling us what's funnier
now
occasionally exactly you get
occasionally a club owner where they'll
get like a complaint or something and
you're like yeah you should probably
should never come back this is for you I
don't even know you're talking about me
if you're gonna complain you're not the
guy for this place cool thank you that's
the right answer always um I was at a
club this weekend I had never been to
tiny little club and if you want to go
somewhere and try new material and it's
like the room is packed and live but
it's a tiny room it's in Vermont flapper
its Vermont
it's the Vermont comedy club oh I want
to go there it's a really cool gig but
the guy used to be a comic uh-huh
and I said to him I said here I go
thanks I had a great week and I said you
know what's underrated is the fact that
you have a bathroom in the green room
yeah and he said I used to be a comic it
was the first thing that we said was we
got to have a bathroom you don't to walk
out through the show we just piss here
or take a dump I know it seems so small
to people who aren't doing it but to
have the bathroom in the green room
because I [ __ ] before every show yeah I
don't want to [ __ ] and then walk out and
see humble brag yeah yeah but I don't
wanna [ __ ] and come out and see you know
half the people who are gonna I would
love if you got like Bill Hicks big like
I know he says always [ __ ] before shows
you gotta do that because heavens like
no I said I always thought you must
everybody I was told when I [ __ ] like
that that's great that's great really
why I meant to uh Edmonton you've
written there
yeah and I was like oh dude when you
said you'll put me by the condo I just
assumed the opener was gonna be here and
be shitty because I'm a comic I'm not
gonna [ __ ] do that yeah it's actually
a nice investment condo and you're like
huge thanks yeah yeah you need former
comics running [ __ ] it makes it so much
but there's a club in San Diego I'm not
gonna say its name where the green room
is right in front of stage awful you
can't come in up you're a prisoner in or
out you're a prisoner yeah it's awful
yeah but they always leave a lot of weed
in that green room that is nice that is
so I generally and there's a Miss
pac-man game right in the middle yeah I
don't I don't play that just because of
a [ __ ] all the [ __ ] yeah payment
issues that all the copa promises I know
hey to get paying a pay to my camera
yeah oh wait you had I know you talked
about you people weren't getting paid oh
yeah it happens a lot too much to where
it's re and I re no this is the car blew
up re red ban and I decided to do a show
during Comic Con which is like you can't
nobody's gonna sell tickets yeah so once
already did it
Joe Rogan I'll come out Joe's like I'll
do it we're like oh [ __ ] and then now
we're selling tickets now Joe Rogan is
so then Doug Benson wants to do it now
Doug Benson's doing it Jim Norton wants
to do it all in the same show what Brian
post a income that - no he did all in
the same show also we don't and this is
before I already blew up so it's like
this small show - this theater show so
we do the show so Friday nights the show
we did the Thursday that was okay Friday
night gets big and then the next night
I'm doing a naughty show and the night
show it was me Tara Patrick it wasn't
even that packed right the owner call
the owner goes I get a call oh hey dude
I forgot to take $300 out of the night
before so I'm gonna take it out of this
when I go oh no that's not happening
these are two different show heels no
I'm doing I go no you're not for an hour
back and forth the best was my
girlfriend I'm we do something called
sending the Jew yeah girlfriend when I
like what are some artists yeah you
can't negotiate cuz she's like I don't
wanna lose this gig you said oh so
they'll like them to a Jew that is the
art form Yeah right so she goes in she's
a pit bull and she's like going out and
she's like I'm done I go get the phone
go okay here's what's gonna happen
I'm gonna call up Joe Rogan Doug Benson
Jim Norton and go I can't pay you what I
agreed to
because this guy's keeping the cash whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa he was fine I'll pay
you over 300 bucks dude he didn't say he
didn't want to me where it's like I get
50 cops per show and I was like okay let
me start selling well he gets 50 comps
he gets to put in 50 people per show
which is now I don't do any cops no cops
allowed yeah we just want people I don't
want few people in there but I get it
when you're not selling tickets like I
get you got to fill up your room and
then Wendy from the counter work does it
great she'll do it if she needs to and
she trusts her but anyway every show had
exactly 50 comps and we sold out of her
show so that
you're like how lucky it was yeah that
you had exactly 150 in there and then
another 50 people even showed up crazy
how that happened every night yeah every
night not even like faking it like 42
one show like exactly fifth I come on
you're keeping that money I worked the
door at the club yeah he urged me
so I came home on sin my manager said
what happened down there
and as like what he talking about and I
talked about you got an email he said I
got a full-page email from this yeah
yeah and amazing how long your emails
when you're blowing out on coke because
he said I broke he said I broke his
microphone and I was like how did they
send you're like yeah I killed that show
yeah yeah he said there's a dent in the
microphone so he's charging you 200
dollars I was like okay so mate for all
their $100 I mean paying for this US
government yeah but he was like he's
like you know it's $200 and he's going
to need a deposit a microphone deposit
for the next time you come down and I
was like hey [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
that's a note of both of those yeah and
just tell them there doesn't have to be
an pass yeah doesn't have to be you next
time yeah but like you're not taking a
microphone yeah how's it that is banana
kick yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so crazy
it's crazy cuz that guy could be perfect
like it's a great place yeah he's a cool
guy sometimes and by the way I love his
staff staff San Diego it's like gasps
like this you're in a the most pretty
seats on the [ __ ] plan so good yeah
right tells nice hotels great hotel had
that weird like showering and you know
that's where just rich dudes pay hot San
Diego chicks oh is the shower dude they
they they had the whoever the nut
stewardess but whoever greets you when
you get to the hotel and there's this
hot chick was like 22 23 and you're like
oh cool and it's just cute and she's
like oh walk in your room like welcome
to room she comes in she goes all the
way in I mean it seemed like that and
I'm like am I not making it seems like I
should make a move here I'm like let's
do it
and then I did know I was like did I
leave something on the table here dad so
funny if you see yeah if there is
something have like you weren't hip to
something that happened yeah you're like
wait is this a thing I learned that when
I was in college I had two times were
two I mean sanely hot women like out of
my league hot chicks laid in my bed and
slept overnight and I cuz you know white
guys we watch romantic comedies and
we're like oh dude this girl wants to be
respected and loved and something to
listen to her once you talk you know
they want knuckle draggers right and I
didn't realize that lent to these ladies
like I hope I wonder how many girls just
want to sleep in her bed yeah no no I
mean I was there the [ __ ] you didn't
do I'm like why are you telling me yeah
I wanna go like we did we laid into your
bed do you think I wanna cuddle on a
twin bed yeah okay they were lying I was
like sure sure sure no and then like
after like two minutes of laying there
she like like sat up and then took her
bra I was like oh okay oh you wanted me
to push you a little bit got it sorry
dude nothing drives me crazy crazier
than white beta Cox this town was
driving me nuts I mean I went to the
concert last night and the crowd was
insane so I go to check-in and there's
this woman with her son and her son is
this super like Femi white guy not
t-shirt I don't care but I was listening
to him and I don't know who the comic
was buying pretty sure it's Tony
Hinchcliffe I know I heard him basically
say enough with white guys we don't need
white guys doing comedy more this chick
more that I'm not like nothing drives me
[ __ ] more not it sits here's what
they've lost it it's it's not I want to
support female comics I like the black
voice it's no more white voice yeah it's
not just like propping somebody up it's
taking someone else down it's kind of
Pauli logic where Paulie when running ZC
started doing better
he wasn't like I want to be the number
one guy so let me do more movies he was
like let me [ __ ] on run as easy and keep
him down yeah we're like that's not the
right answer the right answer is just
propping up people you do like and by
the way I don't even understand
why you need the platform really like
there the people are there for you to
support find the people you want to
support and support
I like Arcade Fire you like [ __ ] yeah
well so supportive but why do you have
to tell me who you don't support yeah
that is what's crazy easy to go I don't
need to know who you like to be ever
[ __ ] go like give a [ __ ] yeah it's
funny you know what would you say is
your crew like the people show up to
your shows white nationalists what would
you say is your is your demo I get I
mean you know it's varied a little bit
but if I had to pick up dead in the mail
college-educated white is it like 25 to
35 that adrià yeah 25 to 35 probably 65%
dude I am so for me and it's interesting
like this weekend really nailed at home
for me but so in for me I'm like 65%
women but like 35 to 50 couples but if
that's okay yeah okay as many couples I
get a lot of gay couples but it really
what you talk about dictates who's gonna
come we're sure so you don't need to
tell me who you don't support just go
support yeah yeah how about this also
buy tickets in advance yeah
don't you I know it's a three dollar
ticket charge but you guys are [ __ ]
killing me because oh yeah right
potheads
I just they're not gonna shoot you
nobody's buying take so everybody's
freaking the [ __ ] out yeah exactly they
get mad but I do the same thing like I'd
go like Star Wars opening day I'm like
two tickets for Star Wars please like
we've been sold out bad
I have this tin foil hat podcast doing
well the demographics are like heavily
men huh heavily men I even say it's like
they're into more conspiracy night
ninety ten eighty twenty makes sense to
me Bob you're a man running that group
of females that come
I'm not lying when I tell you they are
smoking hot right I'm like you listened
to the podcast like oh yeah I love I'm
like you are way too hot to being the
wizard people you know what I'm saying
it's mine like I'm Twitter when they
show up I'm like holy [ __ ] why are you
in - yeah and meanwhile in [ __ ] rumor
Otzi's here he's cocky talky walking the
street now what do you think crystal is
fanbases
women see an object it's crazy when he's
on stage in the main room and you walk
in that room I'm like these people are
not here to see anybody you can tell but
D'Elia oh yeah absolutely
same with Maz yeah with it with air yep
yep yeah you know you follow Mars and
they look at you angry because you're
the worst Maz there is like you're not
budget Arabic Muslim I'm not trying to
be my mother done much to Leah how many
chicks go see to Leah shell they he had
to bring an opener that looks just like
the Leah to handle all the you had to
bring study it's not fair to these women
who share their legs looking for pus
somebody's got to be there for [ __ ]
wait he has to take care of them when I
when people reach out to me online like
how do you think I should meet a woman I
always tell the same thing go to a Chris
D'Elia show the run the run over do
domestic wali we on for [ __ ] was all
these hot chicks who liked him when they
were 12 another 26 27 and they came
shady I was ready to [ __ ] he was
terrible
and they're like oh well I've already
shaved these legs aren't wasting it yeah
hello I guess you were pretty good at
opening it does he still have young
people come to see a show this was 10 15
years ago I don't know I mean like dude
up until recently he was getting a lot
of show time stuff yeah he
that one guy that recently passed away
show time would just buy his things they
were so bad they would do like the hot
tamales of comedy yeah they're special
no that was once his failed Montoya Toya
there was one you'll be Washington
they'd have likes [ __ ]
homeland followed by the [ __ ]
Mexicans of spending by the grand it's
been five grand on a special he say I'll
shoot ten of them if I can sell three I
make my money and then plenty more yeah
and so I remember sitting on a special
somebody and somebody goes actually work
for him like in the back of the commerce
store so maybe once I got back and if I
that's why I said it yeah just [ __ ] off
I'm like okay dead skies in us that wall
you put up a cap city it looks great it
looks great right they kept it you know
and they made us up lighting on you can
make it whatever color you look
somebody's back it looks but you know
one thing I did know that I found out
during the middle of my show don't lean
on that wall
oh it's not still no pop it up it but it
looks it changed the entire little whole
club year and a half two years ago right
did it last last November of almost a
year ago so re took your advice I'm not
gonna put out these special this week I
was just gonna put I just want to put it
out but it was a show on a tour of like
promotion and like start calling those
things and now's like do you record in
advance can we can we all plan it to
drop when you're the same two halves to
35 s so but I want to put out the second
one a little Christian as my Christmas
special you know I just put mine out on
my website yeah you can put them out
separately but like did you devote
campaign for it still like so for me the
one I put I put a campaign but still
like I'm not treating it like you know a
movie where you need to get all your
business done in two weeks it's just not
the way things
it's everything's a slow go on go on
think about this think about think about
but I put it on my website but if it was
what is that they can stream it off of
even mo or they street they stream it
from my Nike I didn't Vimeo because I
didn't want anyone to download it
so as long as you have a passcode that
you get when you buy it you can watch it
anytime you want but you just can't on
my website so what is the what is the
the widget that you use for that
whatever the streaming it's it's you go
to my website me and Joe calm and then
the my website put it on there I can put
your judgement it's five bucks you can
watch it anytime you want but also like
for me when I started to look at the
laws of diminishing returns like I
started outside of Netflix probably HBO
I started look at the other stream place
HBO to be honest I hear yeah but outside
of those two I start to think do I
really want to be do I want it to be on
Amazon nobody's going to amazon for
amazon you could get into the game and
they just haven't you I just have I
don't but for me it flexes nervous fell
Netflix is just putting out too many too
many bad specials
okay here's the here's the rub on that
one you go like if now if I'm an
audience member if I'm a viewer it's
like none of these specials are like
important like I put out a lot of them
Kevin James type of things you know or
rot well rock at least was like a name
but like but like yeah there's a bunch
of shitty ones but the same time they
have so many viewers that it almost
doesn't matter like I'm less interested
as if you were in like oh here's some
new comic let me check him out I'm not
gonna do that as much anymore but the
sheer amount of people who maybe instead
of 80% of those like Comrie viewers
gonna check out everyone it goes down to
15 yeah it's still so many people that
are checking out your special I agree
but I think they would it would be I
would think they'd be doing a better for
comedy as a whole if they were more
selective about what they're putting
thing is they want everyone for each
category so they have like children's
programs yeah
which like you and I won't even notice
that but your your well your daughters
too old now but like a six-year-old
would notice it so a mom is like I'm
gonna get Netflix because they spot they
do stuff from my six year old but I
don't think of any time so it's so with
like the serious or the woke comedy or
the [ __ ] celebrity coming that
doesn't come out of my viewing time now
I'm only getting Segura and whatever and
they're doing a better a better job of
like getting rid of so I don't see the
Bolivian comics do you think um do you
think that people now because it used to
be like people are turning out special
it's right it's not as special and it's
a
go ahead I was gonna say like Chris Rock
it's every three or four years I also
Chris Rock had done one eight eight
years was the last one I also think like
just comedy in general the incubation
period for jokes
I think people rush through them yeah
well a lot of them want to Bieber and
seek' yeah and here's a deal now that
there's so many platforms for the first
time it's on us it's on the comedian's
the ones that are able to put it on
anywhere to say no it's not time yet
yeah just because I have a deal
available just gonna have a network
saying we want you which before is like
how can average in this town I'm looking
for your approval now it's like thank
you I appreciate it I'll be ready in
nineteen months I agree with that and
it's for us to do yeah and I don't think
too many is a problem because music has
six new albums every week trip and lots
of them are selling out theaters true
anyway and you want to see them live you
could go to see key that's right see key
promo code what is it I looked on see
geek today for L 4 Dodgers Red Sox OCO
brunch
punch-drunk go to see key download app
use a promo code c geek and you get 20
dollars towards your first purchase
that's right that means that Dodgers
tickets are only $1,500 dude I buy you
seek last year paid it when saw the
Dodgers high on shrooms which is funny
to really yeah I just lady because you
were talking about um what were you just
talking about okay I lost the thought
but anyways I went there I went a high
on true I do like how to give you like
this is a good deal for tickets this is
a shitty deal for tickets so it's up to
you but like you know I mean you can go
at best deal you can go like cheapest or
you can you can also like I could only
spend up to a thousand up to five
hundred to what whatever it is like of
that and sometimes like no tickets
available okay I wonder if the tick is
gonna be super expensive now because of
Boston I bet they are really come up
let's see well I was just in Joshua Tree
and saw something when I was Truman that
I'd never seen before him my cousin was
a being no have you ever seen a
lightning storm that last are those we
have expensive from far away
I'm from audio it was in the desert it
was like three hours I'm the intern and
not just like well once every 10 seconds
and once every 30 minutes whatever it
was like
once every 15 seconds the whole sky lit
up it was intense and it lasted hours
and I was [ __ ] up but I had never seen
anything like it before in my entire
life that lit up an entire horizon I saw
you do that and you could see it and it
was just like I relied everything I'd be
like that's so cool but it wasn't
raining on us
no music comedy ditch get your shrooms
go and won't charge you jus show he's
doing that's right at the Comedy Store
I think it's a Jew show oh yeah you're
shown a theme show all about yours yeah
yeah yeah all about you yeah all about
Jews see geek loves juice okay hey look
about sick I try to fight ekits for
shrooms in Joshua Tree yeah I'm gonna
see LA live views or like look see that
red dot in the middle that's some guys
look I want $14,000 for there all right
well you're getting a red yeah but
that's right behind home plate dude yeah
for sure right here just like what's
most expensive ticket that's what I'll
get $9,000 a little much now we you know
my son was the bat boy for the Sox when
they played the Dodgers a couple years
ago oh really
and it was the biggest thrill of my life
I don't know about his I don't yet but I
was why he was wearing the uniform and I
was just like oh my that's so cool I
would've been a ball boy dude he would
run out he was a bat boy for the
Cardinals and he was dead he was LaRussa
I was a bat boy dude he runs out and
picks up the bats Wow yeah right your
your he likes a lot of teams no but you
know they would let they sit in the
dugout or sit in the dugout the whole
time and they so I know the guy who ran
the visitors Clubhouse and he was like
this you're someone a batboy because
they don't bring their bat boys with him
I'm like [ __ ] yeah so he gets a I have a
picture of him high-fiving
Albert Pujols as he crossed home plate
after a home run and he's got these
little pale
samer it's so great and he was skinny
little Jew and but they only had pants
that fit grownups so his pants fell down
so he would run out on the field but
with one hand around his belt like this
super fun self dude I would love to get
that for my son I have a son also named
Ari's got that disease where that's way
older and any genes out there so any for
a kid in need a sick kid in need he's
got a balding and you're like why can't
you could like dude I've never gotten
bald my Jam's d-ball pictures out pick
up first pitches everywhere yeah yeah I
would love to catch the burn does I mean
yeah those first pictures out like
what's so cool I threw a first pitch out
in in Fenway its and the guy asked me he
was like how big it shirt you wear I go
just you better make me one that big
enough to cover up my boner cuz I'm
gonna be pretty happy
I went out to first base pan fujur why
they full-on so they said to me they go
hey so we're gonna have somebody else
it's just gonna be you but we got
somebody else who's just coming in
they're gonna do it in front of you but
you're the real guy and I was like well
could should we just haven't do it they
go no no we want you to do it and in
walks this dude in uniform
he's got more medals on him and I'm like
oh oh yeah this is me in Tampa with the
first pitch and I say hey can I throw
out the first pitch you caught the
Yucatan's let's call them
I know double rows this dude is catching
but you in the way there's a there's
nobody at that game yeah yeah if you
called the PR people that's how I didn't
wear the Cubs to and like I'm an
influencer and say I my name's dawn so
this is how many followers I have this
is what I do I'm not google me because
I'm not a desirable but just know that I
have
many people don't - deep do not be
allowed me not a desirable I've never
heard that food like a boot in Auckland
what why heavy boo cuz you're the guy
who went out in front of me so yeah yeah
he's dressed so many metal and they go
ladies and gentlemen it is our honor
this dude has he has apparently rescued
more servicemen where the didn't work
more rescue missions at his playing than
any pilot ever
he's got Purple Heart every medal you
could have this dude has his entire
announcement his bio takes from third
base line to when he gets on top of the
mound there's a crescendo building of
Cheers and when he hits that mound they
go please welcome Captain John Lewis and
the whole place goes throws a strike
standing up when he walks off when they
go she goes okay Europe the guy in the
announcement just goes Josh wolf do you
didn't say anything my foot hadn't even
crossed the third-base line haha there
was a crescendo of boos building up when
I got to the mound the whole place was
like cuz he's like not a here for me my
book dude you're a hero of mine you know
they if it was me they're like he
advocates against the war he says had
their murderers and they needed to say
no to abortions paid for why did one on
his own but you guys could do it no I
would love to what would you say your
favorite anyways he could get past
amazing in another bulb and yeah that's
like you know Yankees in Kansas City but
you'd have to throw it out for Kansas
City I could point but I could just go
to a ballpark
I could go keep say Ken sabers Milwaukee
yeah yes I would still be cool as [ __ ] a
hundred percent what do you think you
pitch it right
yeah I'd roll it I practiced by the way
I do I practice to I practice I took my
brick my brother and practiced I
practiced a HUD I was gonna get
ridiculed you get ridiculed did you guys
see
Jeff Kent in Houston no this guy is the
2001 national league MVP 2001 Jeff
Kent's yeah 2001 Jeff King retired huh
tired by the way should be in the mall
thing like he's never shown I really
will be but he was an [ __ ] total
[ __ ] he was an [ __ ] yeah like
enough of this with the clickings okay
we're professional show that's a son not
a good skirt yeah that's not terrible I
saw it on Twitter and we got a whole
offseason to work on it would be so cool
so I've done a bunch of minor league
parks too which are also fun because the
minor league parks you are a lot of
times in the towns we get dog yeah yeah
you get to wrestle like a 300-pound
woman like it's a good time with those
parks but the modely parks are a lot of
fun they have a great one in Charlotte
if you ever do that Club in Charlotte
that comedy zone know is I've never done
it yet they have one in downtown John
minor league Park which is great
throughout Kansas City they used to put
us up for Stanford Suns right in the
hotels parking lot shared the parking
lot we've got minor league stage you
know he died right Craig glazier not
about drugs no leukemia whoa wait a buck
the I wear the [ __ ] mix it up his
butt and his older brother died like
three months before so what are they
still doing zero Glaser's it's a club
soda clubs closed with Kansas City is
Glaser free it also was a sake club and
he was a bit of his wig was always
crooked and I love the guys with the
wigs they just like are you gonna really
act like we don't know and why is it on
backwards yeah you know I mean like
taking calls hi you're on with Josh wolf
from controlled chaos who's this Oh
cousin Jeff how are you Jeff did you
watch Josh's uh it's the empty show
that's a great show that was a great
show oh you were on this show
yeah I was fun yeah it was fun Jeff are
you alright no dude okay no disrespect
but I've been busy boys today down with
these little goddamn keyhole pussycat
damn servers and stuff man I told this
one today I wanted to sleep around boys
I her out what you were gonna guess
what's leave her out me I don't even
know did he say slave her play with
because you got them vegan teeth - yeah
they're kind of rounded thoughts you
don't need a lot of me but you take a
lot of meat that mouth what's up jab
when you gonna come back to the grade or
whatever at damn little places in
Wilmington where's the grave yeah there
was one in Nashville are you coming oh
yeah great yeah Asheville yeah I already
did loans tour that was where I opened
up this tour but uh it'll be a couple
more years for sure you know I sprinkle
some little cousin livonian drowns and
services that are uh shittily illegal
how about them cowboy we all saw I mean
the Panthers what a great comeback for
Carolina this year this week crazy
haven't seen down in the fourth
all right job all right Jeb thanks for
calling in and ruining everything slaver
out what does that mean I don't even
know what that we never know what he
means
we never know so Danny did you
officially set your record for lease
things set on the show he looks so
[ __ ] young he looks like that [ __ ]
little kid in Hoosiers oh my god
yeah I didn't talk but you know at least
I was interested today usually like if
it just you three talking about football
and so what does that lock of the week
I cannot stand
oh my god no I hate 30 minutes of lock
of the week when we switch it up it's
entertainment okay
I fall asleep Ari's bored to be fair
yeah where's the wife on seems like
because of the conversation oh [ __ ] up
no because you stayed up all night it
was also the Connor could be mayhem
there one of the guards in history and
we're talking about the [ __ ] one in
five Raiders I was so mad at why don't
you say that let's get to [ __ ] UFC
like whoa wait hold on hold on let's
talk with the Raiders for a minute yeah
why you're so full of [ __ ] cuz I got a
demanding Raiders talk we're one in five
deal why are you demanding thank you for
finally changing all right MB are you
excited I'm a Celtics fan so I'm very
excited oh yeah Rondon you really ever
just honestly though anytime if you can
get to the championship you have a
chance yeah talk about four wins out of
seven I mean I that's not necessary true
I think that the Celtics biggest problem
this year will be figuring out how he's
gonna get everybody the ball by the way
what a statement game I you know you
know this about statement game I can't
regular-season Philadelphia is kicking
themselves for [ __ ] getting
demolished last year to the [ __ ]
Celtics and playoffs early on you play
them if you're a seventy Sixers fan and
it's like are you gonna say that was you
guys got [ __ ] lucky we're smarter
we're better now folks has a shot or are
you gonna loop in the Celtics like nah
man
that wasn't a [ __ ] lock that was
[ __ ] what's gonna matter team now than
they did when they took em on exactly so
now it's like [ __ ] you that's gonna
happen again
yeah the guy you should be excited as
you go down to the Western caucus go
down to the Western Conference David Lee
it's a pelican power for real why are
you a palace fan genetic curiosity I was
always a Hornets fan move they move with
them dude they're for real bro Anthony
Davis oh how is into his oh my god and
Mira Tech is [ __ ] better than
cousin's ever was yeah not even what he
could it what he ever was not just there
do you think they'll miss Rondo no no
you don't think so he made well the last
five games of season right the playoffs
dude he was like a player front no
player front are you talking about 11
games
that wasn't all help during the regular
season no it was I mean the Rockettes
looking they still they saw steeper
holes to fill but but Mirotic Davis drew
Alfred Payton is really good at Julius
Julius I love Julia I'm Darius Miller's
not these guys aren't bad do you think
he stays after this year it's an
anything Davison Kinney opt out of for
this year yeah uh he's got some I don't
think it's up to this yet he's never
mentioned leaving so everyone who talks
about him leaving is like of course it's
gonna go is like he's never said
anything
yeah he likes playing it they if I could
finally want to play around him exactly
great coach I mean dude they're for real
dude he's a destroyer I see the
second-best player and you know I think
the best player you think he's the best
player I think if he Davis is the best
player to League do you know the only
reason I the bra I would pick LeBron
it's cuz it's so but I think today's
LeBron is not the best I know but I
think if you look if you look if you put
if you see what LeBron does when he
leaves Cleveland it's like what how bad
they got if you drop Davis off his team
they still win more than Cleveland the
Western Conference will give [ __ ]
house it's hard for me gonna win five
games Cleveland has the ball in his hand
more it's so hard for me to say Davis
his offense is amazing his defense is
Joe so the big four in I mean I guess
you wanna throw quiet in there cuz he's
kind of back so it's like the Greek
freak Kevin Durant LeBron James
Kawhi and uh and Anthony Davis it's it's
save us a little broad that's what I'm
growing one of those two I accept
but you don't think me not throw Durant
in there did because his team it doesn't
matter targets good a team was already a
championship champ yeah they could I
think you could see I mean the only
thing the the the pelicans are missing
is a sharp shooting leaked like rain so
when the games are closed you just give
to them and although Mirotic can [ __ ]
hit threes yeah so but you need it but
you like Ray Allen Johnson you need a
rape you know however you're pulling
packs in a Steve Kerr that's old yeah
yeah you need a guy who lights up judge
it Redick you need to get stuff well
Redick would be amazing on this team but
I'm trying to see the time tell us about
your show one more time I do a show I
hear
Domenic on all things calling he's on
the board I don't know if you have on
the board probably greenlit your show I
do a show here called controlled chaos
which I appreciate it
if at midnight and pee-wee's Playhouse
mix what's it called it's called
controlled chaos that's right I knew
that as a board my success story but
it's not a podcast
it is a live streaming show and we do it
every Tuesday night at 7 o'clock
tomorrow night we won't be doing it here
from the studio because everybody will
be at this is coming yes too low there I
know I'm staying home I'm on the road so
much and but I'm doing it tomorrow from
my house
Sunday night do you wanna do a main room
show yes all right all right guys that's
where the show REI was great having you
in studio thanks bro
oh we're gonna be in here we're gonna do
a hot dog soon November 6th yeah be back
in studio 6 we'll do it that you got a
hot dog eating contest no Rob Hall wrong
hole
are you seeing how many you can shove in
no no we assume we don't we don't really
care who can get the most funny if that
was the bet not if you can do it but how
many I don't think you know what the bet
is
that's what we're doing we're shoving
hot dogs in our asses that's what I say
I might roll pots is author I know I
told him about it said my [ __ ]
kielbasa yeah he goes I mean we've
decided I'm doing Hebrew national really
ask a question like how how do you get
to that bet like I know it didn't start
hotdogs this shows six years what we do
is that we say if I lost a for sure bet
em hmm
I'm willing to pick out of this hat one
of these bets so we go nipple ring a
piercer nipple like would you be able to
do that if it comes up later and we say
if you're positive some team is gonna
win that you're like yeah I would take
that but they're not gonna lose so if
everybody says yes we put that in the
Hat another one let's say is get a
tattoo on your face you know I'm not
gonna boiling right so that won't go in
the Hat
but it would have to be something that
we would have done and so you make this
bet sometimes when you're positive you
win sometimes you just get you just feel
the prick like like this World Series
like
might just overcome with yeah I'm like
[ __ ] it I'll go for it you try to save
them for when you're positive yeah yeah
be real pause what happens so what how
did this bet end up hotdogs in the air
would have and and so are you play
putting the hotdogs in your own ass yes
I am unless fight nannies in and she get
[ __ ] you plugged your [ __ ] it really
seems like if you had a friend you might
be able to do it like Sam's busy I was
only getting like that's your wheel okay
because Sam my theory is you could
probably only do so many yourself but
you could get some but you know what I
mean like I couldn't fit another on in
there the angles wrong yeah I might go
run as easy but local gays please reach
out to Tebow Tripoli or reach out to me
and my website contact at Ari Shaffir
comm we're looking for gays in Phoenix
Joe says he has a bunch and they do mom
well we're gonna do an audition process
for the first 30 minutes to do what the
so anyway me and run as EC made a bet
yeah I'll tell you what the terms were
later but winner the bet was also you
know the bet was will louis c.k come
back in 2018 so if it's 2019 or later
Brenna's ec wins 20 january 31st 2018 or
earlier i commit it's starting to look
like who knows and then now we I want
yeah you won't so the bet was winner
gets to write a non insertion
three-minute gay porn that the loser has
to act no hand jobs allowed touching
fondling all out have you read it
written it on it I'm starting to write
it's gonna be a lot of [ __ ] food
involved by